we know that merging and branching both
have to do with commits but what kind of
relationship does each of these ideas
have with the commit branches are really
just labels that refer to commits so we
have this new kind of relationship the
refers to your relationship so this has
to be branch let's make sure this really
makes sense does diff really have an
operates on relationship with branch
well yes you can diff two commits or you
can dip two branches which is basically
just dipping two commits but there's
sort of different ideas similarly you
can run log on a branch or on a commit
so this must mean that merge goes here
so let's check this one does merge
operate on commits well yeah merge takes
two commits and sort of smooshes them
together into a new commit so I think of
rates on is a pretty good description
there